bill gates is ranked number four this
year on the forbes 400.
he's behind jeff bezos elon musk and
mark zuckerberg who've all seen their
fortunes skyrocket this year because of
their respective companies rising share
prices this is the first time in 30
years he's not the richest or second
richest person in america he's been in
the top two since 1991 and he's been on
the list since 1986.
a little less than a quarter comes from
an estimated 1.3 stake in microsoft
while the rest comes from other
investments his main investment firm
cascade owns stakes in the four seasons
hotels autonation and much more gates
has given away at least 5.7 billion
dollars worth of stock to his ex-wife
melinda french gates as part of their
divorce if his marriage and fortune had
stayed intact gates would be richer than
zuckerberg this year at number three
bill and belinda are still co-chairs of
the gates foundation from 1984 to 2020
they've donated at least
36.8 billion dollars to foundation most
of it in gifts of microsoft stuff in
july the pair announced another 15
billion donation it's the single largest
gift from bill and melinda since the
pair transferred 20 billion dollars in
microsoft stock to the foundation in
2000 at its launch
so after we finalized the 2021 forms 400
list the onslaught of scrutiny related
to team mental health at facebook pushed
down its stock price putting gates back
up to the third richest person in
america
i think it's interesting to see how the
rankings have changed over the last
three decades bull gates was a mainstay
on the list and now there seems to be a
new crop of ultra wealthy billionaires
accumulating more wealth than ever
before